We're on problem 48.
It says if x squared is added
to x, the sum is 42.
So let's just write that out.
If x squared is added to x,
the sum is equal to 42.
Which of the following could
be the value of x?
So essentially they just want
us to solve this equation.
So the easiest way to do it is
to write it as a quadratic
equaling 0 and then
factoring it.
So we could write this as x
squared plus x minus 42 is
equal to 0.
And let's think.
What two numbers when I add
them equal 1, and when I
multiply them equal minus 42?
And the fact that when I
multiply them equals minus 42
tells me that one of them has to
be positive and one of them
has to be negative.
That's the only way that when
you multiply two numbers
you're going to have
a negative number.
So one of them has to be
positive, one of them has to
be negative.
And so when we're adding a
positive and a negative,
you're really finding the
difference between the two.
So the difference between the
two numbers has to be 1 and
their product has to be 42.
And I noticed when I see
42 I immediately
think, oh, 6 and 7.
6 times 7 is 42.
And since when you add them
you get a positive 1, 7's
probably the positive one and
minus 6 or 6 is probably the
negative one.
So let's try it out.
x plus 7 times x minus
6 equal to 0.
And right, 7 times minus
6 is minus 42.
It's really 7x plus minus 6x
is equal to positive x.
Or you could think 7 plus
minus 6 is equal to the
coefficient on the
x, which is 1.
But anyway, that works.
And you could multiply this
out and try it out.
And everything I'm saying,
it's not some voodoo.
The reason why I say that they
have to add up to the 1 is
because when you multiply
this out, that's what
builds up this term.
This 7 times x plus the minus
6 times the other x.
That's what builds this term
when you multiply it out.
This term comes from
the x times the x.
The minus 42 comes from the
7 times the minus 6.
Anyway, now we're
at this point.
We say OK, well how do we get--
we have two things when
you multiply them equal to 0.
Well that means that one of them
or both of them have to
be equal to 0.
So that means that x plus 7 is
equal to 0, which would mean
subtract 7 from both sides.
Which means x is equal
to minus 7.
Or x minus 6 is equal to 0.
Add 6 to both sides. x is
equal to 6. x would
be 6 or minus 7.
And they have one of
the choices there,
which was choice A.
Next problem.
49.
What quantity should be added to
both sides of this equation
to complete the square?
So when you complete the square
you want the thing to
just look like a-- you want
whatever's on the left-hand
side to look like a
perfect square.
And what do I mean by
perfect square?
So if I had x plus a squared,
that's equal to x plus a
times x plus a.
And that's equal to x
times x, x squared.
x times that a, so
that's plus ax.
And now this a times this x.
So that's another ax.
Plus this a times that a.
So plus a squared.
And that's equal to x squared.
Plus-- we have two of these
now-- plus 2ax plus a squared.
So essentially we want this, we
want the left-hand side to
have this form.
So we say, this is
a perfect square.
We can say that's the same thing
as x plus a squared.
So let's think about
how we can do it.
If we have x squared minus 8x
is equal to 5 and I put a
space here for a reason because
we want to add or
subtract something here so it
looks like a perfect square.
So think about it.
When we have this format, in
order for this thing to be a
perfect square, whatever this
coefficient is right here,
this term right here has to
be half of this, squared.
a squared is half
of 2a squared.
So if we took half of minus
8, that's minus 4.
In this case, if we said
2a is equal to 8, a
would be minus 4.
And so minus 4 squared
is what?
It's plus 16.
And this is an equation.
So one you do to one side of an
equation you have to do to
the other side of
the equation.
So you have to say that
that is also equal to.
So you have to add
16 to both sides.
Otherwise you're changing
the equation.
Now this, hopefully you
recognize this as already a
perfect square.
I mean you could look at this
pattern up here or you could
say, OK, if I add minus 4 to
itself twice I get minus 8.
If I multiply it by
itself I get 16.
So this is x minus 4 squared.
That's equal to 25.
And actually, just if you're
curious-- and we did this in
the Khan Academy, we did a
couple of videos on this--
this is how you prove the
quadratic equation.
You essentially complete the
square with arbitrary numbers
a, b, and c, and you get
the quadratic equation.
You know, we show it in 10
minutes, so it's not this
impossibly hard thing
to understand.
They just want to know, what
do you add to both sides of
this equation?
What quantity should be added to
both sides of this equation
to complete the square?
So the answer to this
one was 16.
But they just as equally could
have said, solve it by
completing the square.
And you'd say oh, x minus 4
squared is equal to 25.
So x minus 4 is equal
to plus or minus 5.
And then you could say,
x is equal to plus or
minus 5 plus 4.
And then you could say,
OK, which is 4 plus
positive 5 is 9.
4 plus minus 5 is--
or, minus 1.
Anyway, they didn't ask us
that, so we don't have to
spend too much time
thinking about it.
Let's see, we're
on problem 50.
Let me see, problem 50.
I'll copy and paste 50 and 51.
All right, what are the
solutions for the quadratic
equation x squared plus
6x is equal to 16?
And the temptation here is
really to kind of try to solve
it the way you do a
linear equation.
I don't know, factor out an
x and-- I don't know, do
whatever else.
But the important thing to
recognize is this is a
quadratic equation.
And the easiest way to solve it
is to put all the terms on
one side and then get a
0 on the other side.
And then either factor
it or use the
actual quadratic equation.
Or complete the square, whatever
you need to do.
So let's subtract 16
from both sides.
And you get x squared plus 6x
minus 16 is equal to 0.
I just subtracted 16 from
both sides to get here.
And before just jumping into the
quadratic equation, let's
see if we can factor
it by inspection.
So what two numbers, when I
add them, equal 6-- and we
want positive 6-- and when I
multiply them equal minus 16?
And once again, since it's a
minus 16, if you multiply two
numbers you get a
negative number.
They have to be different
signs.
One has to be positive and
one has to be negative.
And their difference will be 6
because one's positive and
one's negative.
So let me think about it.
So if I had minus-- well,
8 and 2 is equal to 16.
And they're 6 apart.
So if I did plus 8 and
minus 2-- right.
Plus 8 and minus 2
is positive 6.
So it's x plus 8 times
x minus 2.
And that really just takes
a lot of practice.
You say, OK, what two numbers?
16.
OK.
8 and 2.
Well they're going to have
to be different signs.
But I have a positive one here,
so whichever number's
larger is probably going
to be the positive one.
So positive 8 and minus 2.
Yeah, when you add them up,
they equal minus 6.
Yeah, it works.
So you set that equal to 0.
And you say OK, this has to be
equal to 0, or that has to be
equal to 0.
So x is either equal
to minus 8.
If you say x plus 8 is equal to
0 then subtract 8 from both
sides, you get x is
equal to minus 8.
I shouldn't have skipped
that step, but
I'll do the step here.
Or you could say x minus
2 is equal to 0.
Add 2 to both sides, you
get x is equal to 2.
What x makes this
term equal to 0?
And you could look at
it from inspection.
So x could either be minus 8
or 2, and that is choice C.
Problem 51.
Leanne correctly solved the
equation x squared plus 4x
equals 6 by completing
the square.
Which equation is part
of her solution?
OK, so the same thing.
x squared plus 4x.
And when you complete the square
you're going to add
something here.
So I'm going to leave
a little blank.
Is equal to 6.
So what could I add here that
makes this expression look
like a perfect square?
Well, got to the pattern
that we did a
couple of problems ago.
Whatever's here should be the
square of half of this.
So 4-- well, half
of that is 2.
2 squared is 4.
So I should add 4
to that side.
If I add 4 to that side,
I have to add 4 to
this side as well.
And now this 2 plus
2 is equal to 4.
2 times 2 is equal to 4.
So this is x plus 2 squared.
And I really want you to
get the intuition.
Don't memorize the steps for
completing the square.
I want you to really
understand why.
This is the square
of half of that.
And we showed it in
the beginning.
Square a lot of binomials and
see for yourself that that's
always going to be the case.
Anyway, so this is
x plus 2 squared.
That's going to be equal to--
6 plus 4 is equal to 10.
And that is choice B.
I think we have time
for one more.
One more problem, problem 52.
Copied it and now I
have pasted it.
Carter is solving this equation
by factoring.
Which expression could be one
of his correct factors?
Once again, I like to personally
separate out the
number that goes into
all of them.
And all of these are
divisible by 5.
And that just simplifies
it in my head.
So if I divide all of these by
5-- actually, I could just
divide both sides of
this equation by 5.
0 divided by 5 is 0.
And then that left side divided
by 5 becomes 2x
squared minus 5x plus
3 is equal to 0.
So if this is 2x squared here,
so it's going to be two
numbers when you multiply them
equal 3 and when you-- so
let's think about this
a little bit.
Actually, let me write it down
here because I think I'll need
more space.
2x squared minus 5x plus
3 is equal to 0.
And I just divided both
sides of the equation
by 5 to get to this.
So let's see what
we can do here.
So we have a 2x squared here
and they already kind of
hinted to us that we're going
to have an integer solution,
so we can factor this.
So the intuition is that this is
going to be 2x times-- you
know, plus something.
Plus a.
Times-- well what times?
Times probably x, right?
2x times x is 2x squared.
Now that wouldn't be completely
obvious if they
didn't already tell us that
we could factor this.
You might have to use a
quadratic equation or something.
Actually, the quadratic equation
wouldn't be something
crazy to use here because
you can just
kind of plug and chug.
But let's see if we can
get the intuition.
So it's going to be 2x plus
something times x plus
something else.
If we were to multiply this out,
you get 2x times x is 2x
squared as it should.
2x times b is plus 2bx.
a times x is plus ax.
a times b is plus ab.
And so let's see what we get.
So plus 2b plus ax plus ab.
2x squared.
OK, now can do pattern
matching.
This was our original thing.
So 2 times b plus a has to be
equal to-- this term is the
same thing as this
term right here.
And that term has to be
the same thing as
that term right there.
So first of all, I have
a positive 3 here.
So I'm multiplying two numbers
to get a positive 3.
So they either have to be both
positive or both negative.
And then the other interesting
thing is we have-- when I take
2 times one of them plus
the other one, I
get a negative number.
So the only way when you're
dealing with negative numbers,
and when you just multiply it
times a positive and add them
to each other you get another
negative number, is if they're
both negative.
This told us they both
have to be negative
because this is positive.
And then since when you add
them without any negative
signs you get a negative number,
it tells you that that
has to be negative as well.
So let's see.
Let's just try 3-- negative
3 and negative 1.
If negative 3 and negative 1.
So you're right.
Yeah.
If b is equal to minus 1 and a
is equal to minus 3, then 2
times minus 1 is minus 2.
Minus 3.
Right, so b is equal to minus
1 and a is equal to minus 3.
This is a bit of an
art form here.
I mean there isn't like a plug
and chug, very mechanical way
of doing this.
The quadratic equation is one,
but this is the best way that,
at least, I know how to
do these without.
So, we know what a and b is.
So it's 2x-- a is minus 3.
2x minus 3 times x plus
b. b is minus 1.
So that's the factorization.
So 2x minus 3 times x
minus 1, which one?
They have this one right here.
2x minus 3.
And I'm all out of time.
See you in the next video.